une première mondiale à saint germes en
les installer sur un tapis roulant
devant le château l'ultra trail heure
fabrice pancrazi a parcouru 160
kilomètres avec 10000 mètres de dénivelé
sur trois jours cette performance
inédite a été organisée pendant la
virade des rois pour vaincre la
mucoviscidose
je vous avoue je suis totalement épuisé
j'ai dormi une heure la nuit dernière
avant-hier et 2h cette nuit et je
dormais dans ma voiture qui est juste en
face donc je suis totalement épuisé et
puis il ya l'effort physique qui est
extrêmement difficile puisque sur un
tapis on fait toujours le même geste
c'est donc dire que ce sont toujours les
mêmes muscles qu'il travaille pendant
ces quarante cinq heures d'efforts de ce
vendredi 25 au dimanche 27 septembre le
sportif a également pu partager cette
aventure avec de nombreux passants grâce
un deuxième tapis installés juste à côté
de lui
l'idée était aussi de faire participer
les gens qui qui donne aussi à
le public et puis les amis qui viennent
encourager et donc un tapis et ils l'ont
accompagnée elle a aussi avec des
exploits des gens qui ont fait 30 km de
nuit
à plus de 10 km h de moyenne au total
l'ultra trail de fabrice a permis de
récolter plus de 9000 euros vous pouvez
continuer à faire vos dons à
l'association pendant encore un mois par
téléphone
[Applaudissements]